how are we feeling for staying in school
are you nervous but you exhausted
hopeless and I don't enjoy the things
that I once loved where are you getting
this from this is all wash commercial
obviously there's this really sweet guy
in my yoga class I mean it separated for
five months girls it's my birthday so
I'd like to offer to buy you drinks
really managers making me ask for your
ID okay by the way I'm definitely old
enough to drink alcohol
me too obviously I just always act out
on my birthday it's like my own personal
near dude I just feel like just reel it
back to normal
did you wash this I did but only because
I was doing a load and I've been up
since 5:30 hurry up you guys
what are you guys doing home I thought
Nana was taking your school you're
acting weird
oh my god thank you very much for
everything
mrs. um and you are
I like them namaste I'm teddy but
they're dead broke so I thought they
could stay here stay here try looking at
this as something that could be sort of
exciting okay guys let's just do our
best not to grab each other style uh-oh
she grabbed that and flows down toilet I
don't know your ex but he must be some
kind of maniac I'll let you slip through
his head you know I'm 40 right I like
the ballpark oh my god tell me you see
I'm filthy
what are you doing here oh god I just
can't think straight is that one of
[Music]
did you tie dad about your play please
stay for it daddy what is it again next
exciting I miss my family best fixes you
make a decision about your life when
you're 25 years old you think that's not
like a good life decision for the rest
of your life seem to be handling
everything really well
okay let's eat
[Music]
it's gonna be good bye good night okay
[Music]
you